sports royalty and royals collided on
tuesday when prince william and kate
middleton were joined by david beckham
at
england's football match against germany
it's quite exciting actually
and they couldn't have seemed happier
watching their country win the game
2-0 securing the team's place in the
quarterfinals
the vip section of wembley stadium also
featured
ed sheeran
the music star taking a break from his
courtney cox collabs to be on hand for
england's big win
game day was also a family affair with
prince william and seven-year-old prince
george
twinning in their suits and ties as they
cheered on the home
team david was also joined by his son
romeo
the beckhams were snapped sharing this
celebratory moment
the exciting event followed a day of
royal duties for prince william and
queen elizabeth
among their many stops on monday the
duke of cambridge accompanied
his grandmother on a soda factory tour
in scotland
following the duke and duchess of sussex
welcoming their second child earlier
this month
william and harry are set to reunite in
mere days
when the brothers attend the unveiling
of a princess diana statue on july first
we don't believe that megan will come
over to the uk
in july of the unveiling of the diana
statue it's really a tall order
for her with such small children and of
course still during a pandemic which
is restricting transatlantic travel so
we are expecting him
to be there alongside william to unveil
this statue which has been a long time
coming and we know that there have been
some really quite
deep problems between harry and william
difficulties between
harry and his father and i think it's
everyone's hope that this little baby
will
be a peace offering in many ways and
that she will help to
bring this divided family back together
when you are a parent it changes
everything for
for you david has a long history with
the family and gave e.t
his reaction to harry and meghan's royal
exit
you know you did face some criticism
when you left the uk went to play for la
galaxy so you made that transition that
move
have you spoken to your friends harry
and megan about their move over here to
north america how they
how are they adjusting what are they
making of this new life no i
you know i haven't spoken to to harry
you know about him obviously moving you
know we speak as friends and that's
that's the most important thing for me
you know he he's enjoying
i think he's enjoying being a young
father a father for the first time
and that's that's what we've always
spoke about
he always needs to be happy he needs to
be happy we love him
and he's an amazing person and that's
what's the most important thing but
i'm proud to see him you know growing up
as a
as an individual and being that person
you know the
every father wants to be every father
wants to be loving to their
their children and and that's what
that's what he that's what i see with
[Music]
him
you